you get caught up in it in Hollywood you
get caught up in it like I was like yeah
I want to do movies and I want to do
another movie and then this movie will
help me do another thing and get bigger
I don't want to I don't want to get
bigger I just want to have my fans I
want to rock with you [__] I
want to talk on this podcast I want to
be my family
that's it dude
do I want to go to the
soft opening of some nah
yeah but nah you know who's gonna be
there who this new up-and-coming rapper
and a guy who cooks food on TV nah I'm
good
yeah but it might help you I don't
that's okay
GQ is going to be there and so it
doesn't matter
who is Calvin gonna be there no I'm good
my wife she gonna be there
she don't want to go I'm good she could
go to bed at 9 30 p.m because she's
pregnant and I'll just watch bad movie
I'll just watch you know what I'll watch
I'll watch the last 10 movies Bruce
Willis made that's what I'll watch
the movies that they forced him to be in
rather than hang out with [__] baby
face and uh Dr Drew who by the way I
love Dr Drew and I'm sure Babyface is a
nice guy time to change your name though
huh one time I was at an event I can't
remember what the hell it was but it was
like you should go and I was like all
right I'll go I used to follow Nikki
Whalen I think she's a [__] good
actress and I was like oh she's [__]
cool and you know this is years ago she
would say oh you're so funny I'm like oh
yeah that's [__] cool whatever she
had a boyfriend you know I tried to hang
out with her like [__] nine years ago
and then uh and then she was like uh
she always would be like haha or
something I was like oh she's not
interested or whatever it was all good
and then uh I saw her at an event and I
was like ah [__] hey what's up how
you doing and I go to like give her a
hug and she goes oh okay and she was so
weird about it and I was like oh [__]
all right okay
we're not people I'm done then
I'm done then I'm out I'm out I'm not
coming to these [__] GQ parties and
[__] you got to stand next to a [__]
sweaty guy that was like
that's in [__] What's that show well
Modern Family
and uh
and Josh Peck and by the way I love Josh
Peck but it's like what am I doing here
I went to one and I was with Aaron Paul
all night and then I got pink eye the
next day I'm texting Aaron Paul do you
have pink eye no
like what is Hollywood
it's so weird it's such a rat race once
you get unhooked from The Matrix once
you get unhooked and you realize oh I'm
just a guy who [__] speaks to my fans
I'm I love you [__] and I don't
even like the word fans I get it I know
you are but also your people and this is
why I say it's a cult dude we got to get
in that tall grass and build that
[__] log cabin and
a guy with a podcast
that's what's up dude
G-Unit that's what's up crazy crazy
crazy crazy
crazy
crazy congratulations